but you went on the rogan show which i
thought was super dope
did you get like i feel like that's
another guy who we're talking about who
like just speaks freely for three or
four hours at a time so he's bound to
say some [ __ ] that can piss
any amount of people off did you get any
like blow back from anybody for
no man actually i got a lot of love from
that of course
it was a great interview thank you
appreciate it you guys were highs [ __ ]
we were stoned i i just woke up i was
really excited to do it
first of all and then when i got there
there was no like real format or
anything
it was just like yo just sit down and we
just started talking so
um yeah i mean the vibe that i got from
him
and of course is is authentic and he's a
cool ass dude
but he just says what he thinks is is
real and what he believes and if he
believes it he believes it if he doesn't
he'll actually talk to you but he's not
really
going to challenge your opinion he's
just going to say what he believes
and i i i'm i'm cool with that like
everybody's standing on i also like the
fact he's very
open to your perspective right like he'd
be like oh [ __ ] i didn't even look at it
that way you know what i mean like he
has people from
all sides see nobody get on there argue
with joe
they just talk everybody just talks but
they don't always agree they're not
saying the same exact thing
but they're not [ __ ] going back and
forth and [ __ ] i feel like if the world
was like that'd be big
are we just yelling at each other yeah i
mean anything or tweeting at each other
really
with lots of caps yeah it's weird i
don't even [ __ ] with
a lot of that type of stuff y'all are my
homies so it's like y'all could get
anything you know what i mean
but really like on the outside and you
know uh
just shock value and all of that stuff
clickbait
is it's a dark real scary place